hello
and then
level check one two three four five I'm
about an inch away from the mic which is
ideal
test test is that all right I speak
loudly
foreign
come on
good morning everybody and welcome to
the meeting if we can make a start turn
the mic on yeah it is on off all right
yeah
um first of all I'll be reading out the
protocol and apologies afternoon's
minutes and then I my announcements I
want to address the group that's over
here from in support of timoth saving
timoth hospital so we'll start by
reading out the protocol
uh no fire alarm test is planned should
the fire alarm sound please leave the
room and meet by the stand at the far
end of the car park
uh please raise your hand if you wish to
speak and a boom microphone will be
brought over to you if you don't speak
into the microphone you'll not be heard
on the live stream otherwise please
remain seated and please keep points
short and I ask that members and not to
repeat the points that are already been
raised voting will be by a show of hands
and should the meeting be adjourned any
filming uh mercies unless the express
permission from those being filmed has
been obtained during any adjournment I
would ask that members uh the public and
officers please leave the room until the
meeting
reconvenes right item one for the
meeting is apologies for absence
may I have that please Sarah have
apologies from counselors cook Hayes
foden Nuttall Gribble Thorne Jenks Eden
and tomb and apologies from the managing
director
thank you very much Sarah
we moved to item two which is the
minutes of the meetings on the 17th of
November and the 29th of November may I
have a proposal for those minutes
happy to Pro Set and seconded by Council
junhurst
all right can I have a show of hands
please to accept those minutes
okay uh it looks as they'll be carried
those uh against those minutes anything
wrong anybody abstaining from those
minutes
usually get you know three people at the
back thank you very much the minutes are
carried thank you very much
so I moved to item three announcements
and I'd like to welcome uh in the
announcements here the group that has
turned out in the rain uh in support of
trying to retain timoth Hospital
uh
their motion unfortunately put forward
by David Cox he's way down the agenda
and uh we've got or uh or An Almighty
amount of business to consume before
that uh and the the officers and the
councilors are uh have asked me to stick
to the running order we're not ducking
out of this you can watch the whole
meeting Live on YouTube when you go home
later
the executive incidentally are mindful
to support this Motion in which case it
comes back to uh full Council if it goes
to that if we have a debate later on in
the day we're going to need two-thirds
of members to support that debate to
debate it here and there which will be
later on but we can't really afford the
time with the local plan today on the
agenda this local plan is
for the benefit of the public is to
consider another another 4 530 new homes
in the whole of teambridge up till 2040
building at a rate of 741 homes a year
so somebody kindly in the from the
hospital group stood up and looked at me
very hard and said well surely we're
going to need this Hospital open to uh
uh cater for all these new homes and
certainly has a valid point so all I
would like to say is thank you very much
to the group for coming it's not rude to
disappear if you want to hear some of
this debate on on the rest of things
we're ex we've all brought sandwiches
here as counselors today and we're
expecting this To Be An Almighty long
meeting
those of you that might remember I did
chair the local plan meeting in 2012.
uh and we were here till 10 to six in
the evening with umpteen breaks and I
proposed to have breaks this morning
Comfort breaks a a suitable point we're
having a break for lunch and coming back
as the meeting goes on throughout the
day so it's not going to be one of those
Almighty long meetings
so I hope the group are satisfied we've
got with what I've said to them over
there and once again thank you for uh
turning out uh the Press have got all
the photos they need
etc etc so I think you've made your
point very very well and and thank you
for turning out right if I may move on
please to the next item which is public
questions uh item five there are no
we have declarations oh I've skipped one
I'm awfully sorry after my announcement
yeah very good uh item four is
Declarations of Interest right councilor
Sally Morgan
um I'm just going to declare a personal
interest on an aspect of the local plan
it's a an aspect that I was being have
been involved in as um
a campaigner it's not a pecuniary
interest so I will stay and debate and
vote on the item thank you okay
thank you are there are there any other
Declarations of Interest
no thank you very much indeed all right
we moved to public questions item five
and I believe there are no public
questions that's what I thought
which gets us straight away onto uh item
six uh which is the council tax base uh
for 2023 stroke 24 and the executive
member for Corporate Services uh I'm
looking at now
thank you thank you very much Mr
chairman
Mr chairman setting the council tax base
is a statutory responsibility of this
Council
the town the council tax base is the
estimate number of band D equivalent
properties in the district for the next
year there's a small allowance for
likely collection losses
the details are shown in section one of
appendix a the council tax for each of
the District Council
County fire police and town and Parish
parishes multiplied by the council tax
base gives the income or the precept
which the district pays to each
Authority
we the district council are responsible
for collecting those taxes
I would like to thank our Chief
Financial Officer Martin flintcroft and
his team for all the work on this
so I propose Mr chairman that the
council approved the council tax base of
50 215 for the 2023-24 at appendix a of
the report thank you
and it's proposed by councilor Kinder
seconded by
councilor Connor have you got that Sarah
yeah well done well done
uh I'm now opening this up to debate
are there any members that wish to speak
on it before we go to the recommendation
right so the recommendation uh is as it
says that the council resolve uh to
approve the council tax base of fifty
thousand two hundred and fifteen for the
23 24 at appendix a of the Agenda Report
all those in favor please
foreign
those against please obviously
those abstaining
okay so that is carried thank you very
much indeed uh members
Mr now I'm managing to push things along
uh right so it's now on to item seven
um Pages 23 to 142 recommendation from
the executive uh about the
2022 council tax reduction scheme and
I'm once again
I'm looking at councilor Keeling to
introduce it thank you very much Mr
chairman I won't keep you too long on
this we are now in the third year of
running of income-based council tax
reduction scheme ensuring low-income
working households can quickly and
easily apply to help towards their
council tax bills
for the vast majority of claimants those
receiving Universal Credit this is a new
income banded approach
which provides continued continuality
and stability maintaining constant
levels of support despite small amounts
fluctuating in their income our scheme
continues to provide support up to a
maximum of 100 percent providing relief
for payments of council tax for those on
the lowest incomes in our community
remains committed to helping our most
financially vulnerable households and
has maintained maximum support at 100
percent ever since the scheme was
localized
although still higher than before the
pandemic which we saw a significant
increase in the caseload the cost of the
scheme has now started to reduce with
the UK looking like we might enter
recession costs May again start to rise
but but with residents still recovering
from the economic impacts of the
pandemic and now dealing with the cost
of living crisis
I feel now is not the time to be cutting
the sport we need to step up with that
in mind I am proposing we carry forward
the scheme unchanged into 2324 providing
our lowest income households with
financial stability and certainty as we
move forward in these challenging times
Mr chairman colleagues I have looked
carefully at the working age council tax
reduction and exemption hardship case
studies and it is clear to me that we
are helping those residents who find
themselves in a situation where if they
did not have the 100 safety net
families would get deeper into financial
debt with the cost of collection to this
Council in effect we are supporting
we support and request an appropriate
advice to enable the customers to make
changes to their budgeting
I'm also proposing that we inbuilt
provision within the scheme to protect
claimants from losing support as a
result of the annual increase in
National benefits
since this report was prepared the
government has confirmed it will uplift
primary benefits by the rate of CPI
as at the end of September the income
banded thresholds will need to be raised
accordingly to ensure no one in receipt
of state benefits suffers a drop in
council tax support as a direct result
of the annual cost of living increase in
their benefits
I would like to thank the service lead
for revenue and benefits and customers
support Tracy Hooper and her team for
their hard work on this
so therefore Mr chairman I propose that
the council tax reduction scheme
attached in appendix a be adopted for
the year
2023-24 with income amounts updated in
line with an annual up rating in primary
benefits thank you Mr chairman
proposed and seconded Sarah got that all
right
right before we go to the vote does
anybody wish to speak on this item yes
there is councilor Cox
just want to congratulate councilor
Keeling on the keeping the scheme going
it's really important to people citizens
of advice tell me that uh council tax
debt across Devon is is a serious is
worse now than the um the old payday
loans which are thankfully inter ended
so it's really good that we are doing
this we I think we're one of only 22
councils in the entire country that does
this though I do understand the
by-election in North Devon has changed
control of North Devon District Council
and they intend to uh introduce such a
scheme as ours so we are I think we
should be very proud of what we're doing
to help the very poorest in our
community by taking away the council tax
liability
foreign
thank you councilor Cox and anybody else
like to speak on the item at all
right well you heard the recommendation
just read out a second ago don't need to
me to read it out again all those in
favor of the recommendation
those against
any abstentions
unanimous Sarah thank you
thank you very much
uh right we move on from that one to
item eight
um a recommendation from the executive
of the 3rd of January uh re-council tax
premiums to consider that recommendation
and we're looking at again councilor
Keeling thank you sorry there Mr
chairman it's me again
um it's very important this very
important so Mr chairman uh tax premiums
if I can quote the leveling up and
regeneration Bill includes the following
provision the bill recognizes the impact
that high levels of Second Home
Ownership can have in some areas and
we'll introduce a new discretionary
council tax premium on a second home of
up to 100 percent it will also allow
councils to apply a council tax premium
of up to 100 on homes which have been
empty for longer than one year rather
than the two years as is current
this will encourage more empty homes
into productive use while enabling
councils to raise and retain additional
Revenue to support local services
so Mr chairman based on current numbers
of properties held on our records
1240 would fall into this criteria
income generated from the premium would
be shared across preceptors including
County police fire and towns of barrages
teambridge would retain around nine
percent which is about 225 000 pounds
we feel that the actual amount of
additional income generated could be
significantly lower as a result of the
concerns noted in 2.3 2.4 and 2.5 set
out
the number of properties fluctuate on a
daily basis and is likely to be reduced
if when the premiums are announced with
some Council taxpayers choosing to sell
rent out or even move into their second
homes
again I would like to thank the service
lead for revenue and benefits and
customer support Tracy Hooper for her
and her team for the hard work on this
Mr chairman I propose the council
accepts a the application of the current
premium of 100 for all dwellings which
are unoccupied and sustainable
substantially unfurnished empty
dwellings
after the first year instead of the
second with effect from the 1st of April
2024
B
the application of a premium of 100 for
all dwellings which are unoccupied
substantially
furnished with effect from the 1st of
April 2024 and
see that the 151 officer be given
delegated powers in consultation with
the irrelevant executive member to
implement the policy in line with the
council's requirements and any guidance
given by the Secretary of State thank
you Mr chairman
you got that Sarah yeah indeed right
members um opening this one up to debate
as you've heard the recommendations a b
and c is there anybody would like to
speak on this councilor bulovan
thank you overall I mean
I approve of the proposals you use words
like substantially within your
definitions can we have a definition of
what that actually means please
it's a home that has Furniture within it
that is is lived in
um thank you for that the only concern I
have obviously is what represents is it
a chair left in a house is it a fully
furnished house
you know there must be some definitive
method around which the calculations can
be based thank you councilor comment
will try to answer chairman I suspect
substantially is a word used in the
legislation perhaps uh as the officers
here might be able to live Tracy could
just update the Council on what that
might mean
yes right at the back from microphone
thank you
thank you for that information
thank you thank you chair
um yes substantially is a term that is
that is it's not defined in legislation
as much by case law so we do have to
look at each case on its merits but
essentially a house needs to be capable
of occupation so you would expect to see
um you would expect to see a bed you
would expect to see a cooker you would
expect to see a fridge you would expect
to see somewhere to be able to eat a
meal you would expect to have perhaps a
sofa you would expect flooring so um
it's it's really a common sense approach
I suppose you could suggest that you
would need to expect someone to be able
to live in the property with the usual
Furnishings in place
I hope that helps
I think it might help here councilor
Russell
Mr query
um if a flat or a home is substantially
furnished then are they paying business
rate or domestic rate
um because this was always a question
raised you know with winter let's and
this kind of thing when properties are
are empty in the winter time thank you I
think Tracy Hooper's best place to
answer that thank you
thank you
um yes a flat that's used as a domestic
residence will be the same as any
property would be charged council tax
it's only if it's used for Holiday
letting purposes that it could
potentially be charged business rates
and it will only be charged business
rates if it meets certain criteria and
that criteria is being strengthened from
1st of April this year by new government
legislation that will require properties
to be available for let for 140 days per
year and actually let for 70 of those
days and and there will be evidence
businesses will be required to provide
evidence to substantiate their their
application for business rates liability
I think that's very helpful to know it
applies a lot in my patch at children
this so thank you very much
uh any other speakers
anybody else well you've heard the a b
and c recommendations from councilor
clearly was seconded maybe go to the
vote on this please those in favor
those against
those wishing to abstain
one abstention
carried thank you very much
now we move on to item nine and the
agenda uh the implications of Michael
goe's statement on the changes to the
planning system and I think this falls
to the portfolio holder to update us
thank you Gary
Taylor
thank you Mr chairman Mr chairman
members item nine concerns the officer
report on the letter of the 5th of
December 2022 from Michael govemp to all
members of parliament and the subsequent
written ministerial statement published
on the 6th of December relating to
proposed changes to the planning system
in England alongside the leveling up and
regeneration bill
copies of these respective documents are
included at appendices one and two of
the officer report
we'll recall Council was due to consider
the proposed submissions to draft new
local plan at the meeting of the 15th of
December last year
the tenths of the letter and the
ministerial statement however raised
several issues that require further
consideration leading to the
postponement of that meeting to allow
officers and members the opportunity to
reflect on what was said and meant and
to understand the potential implications
for the council emerging local plan
a meeting of the Cross party local plan
working group was subsequently convened
on the 15th of December meetings of
which all main members are regularly
invited
following this December meeting letters
were sent to Anne-Marie Morris MP and to
Mel stride MP seeking further
clarification on the statement founded
appendix 3.
on the 22nd of December the government
published its consultation on changes to
the National planning policy framework
this government consultation runs until
the 2nd of March and while none of the
questions posed have been considered to
Warrant a delay to the local plan
process
a full review of the consultation
documents will be undertaken with the
local plan working group in the coming
weeks to help inform the council's
response as we have done previously to
consultations on the white paper
planning white paper
today's report provides members with an
overview and a recommendation based on
the content of the Secretary of State's
letter and written ministerial statement
a written ministerial statement is an
expression of government policy however
until such time as the changes are
brought into effect the starting point
for decision making Remains the existing
National planning policy framework
policies
including the numbers used in the plan
where housing need in teambridge is
established using the standard method
formula
an appraisal of how the proposed changes
relate to the draft new local plan can
be found at Section 3 while the various
risks in delaying or halting the
consultation and submission process are
further covered at section 4.
members will note that the protections
offered from the Secretary of State's
letter relates to plans at an advanced
stage of preparation
this would not apply to teambridge based
on the current local plan
such protections would help prevent
landowners using the appeals process to
try to gain permission for development
on unwelcome unallocated sites
these protections include only having to
demonstrate a four-year supply of
housing land rather than the current
five-year Supply and would apply to
authorities which have consulted on a
plan with both a policies map and
proposed allocations towards meeting
housing needs as our new draft plan does
today
undertaking the consultation and
submitting the local plan to the
planning inspectorate would mean the
council would then benefit from this
protection
in conclusion therefore it is considered
that the letter from the Secretary of
State and the consultation on the
national planning policy framework do
not raise new issues that would justify
pausing the process
I would therefore propose Mr chairman
that as set out we note in one the
content of this report and its
appendices and a two proceed to consider
the report on the local plane
consultation as set out in the agenda
thank you for the proposal is somebody
seconding that Council of con it is
going to second that proposal
I'm opening this up to debate and now
would anybody like to say anything
please raise your hand Council bulovan
thank you for the report and thank you
for the copies of the letter from the
Secretary of State
the question I have is I believe that
the current work that's been carried out
is appropriate for a team we should look
at my issue relates to the question of
how do we determine how many houses team
Ridge needs in future as laid down in
the letter from the Secretary of State
historically since 1911. the census has
shown an almost straight line increase
each 10-year period of 8.4 percent in a
number of households
in teambridge
that
rate of growth implies that we need to
be building approximately a minimum of
600 oh it's actually 580 homes per year
just to meet that historical growth
over the last four years we've
substantially fallen short of that
number
therefore how is it in what framework
are we going to put in place to
establish a realistic number for the
district as we move forward and when can
we expect to have that sort of
information available for us to discuss
thank you
let's go to councilor Taylor first but
rather than an officer try to answer at
the back all right thank you chair So
currently we have the national planning
policy Frameworks standard method
formula and that is the number that we
are that we continue to be directed at
that number was hovering at around the
760 Mark
um a year or two ago it's now
741 I believe and we will be using that
as the basis uh for the time being at
least
for for for the number as we have been
directed by the MP micro Gove
was it Michelle laskam the officer at
the back were looking to comment on this
as well uh I thank you Gary for your
very good answer
thank you chair
um so uh obviously as uh Council Taylor
has said we are currently using
um under the system of the existing mppf
which is um in place for this plan
um
following this uh plan and in due course
as we know more certainty around whether
or not the changes in the mppf do come
into Force we will look to review the
housing figure using up-to-date census
data which is due to be published and
2024 and that will inform the next
iteration of the plan
uh thank you very much
um anybody else wishing to speak
um councilor Richard Dawes
hi thank you
um
a couple of points actually the uh the
first one is the uh in relation to
Michael gove's comments and uh and and
Publications which uh uh when uh uh in
headline terms uh sort of appear quite
encouraging but when you get into the
detail realize it's some sort of uh
appeasement and and electioneering on
behalf of the conservative party uh so
incredibly disappointing uh getting into
the detail of that and what potentially
actually gives
um the council and and districts to to
rail back on on housing numbers what we
have seen however is is some Progressive
and uh and and more
um environmentally uh uh caring councils
uh take a take an approach where they've
said that they aren't going to uh adhere
to uh the the standard method and
they're going to choose their own
housing targets I think I think Bristol
uh would be one of those authorities and
Wiltshire as well uh has been mentioned
and and it's usually disappointing that
since we're elected that the the even
now uh the council hasn't read uh the
report that was prepared by Alice
curtswell Parish Council in 2012 uh that
outlined the housing number was closer
to 444 uh houses needed for the district
uh a number that's sort of been verified
by
um uh the CPR ra
um
and uh so so that's uh yeah it's just a
matter of matter of fact that the the
council hasn't taken alternative
approach it does have 41 of the district
in the national park and it is uh has
the issues of coastal towns as well so
um very disappointed to see that the
council just counts out to National
Housing numbers and and uh and operate
in a very subservient way
uh thank you very much councilor towards
that before I come to councilor McGregor
and uh councilor Boulevard uh councilor
Gary Taylor would like to reply to that
councilor Taylor uh thank you very much
chair I do consider this authority to be
a progressive Council but I also could
it should be a responsible Council other
councils who may fit who may have the
the uh the the luxury of a of a higher
um uh five-year housing land Supply ours
currently stands at 6.14
um may be able to take a little bit of
extra time I know Stockport for instance
are also doing the same but we find
ourselves in the uh in the horns of our
dilemma here because we have not only a
housing land Supply at 6.15 land Supply
at 6.14 years we also have a three-year
housing delivery test that's about fail
and may if it if it doesn't drop us into
the uh the area of the presumption in
favor of sustainable development by
being under 75 percent of the total over
the last three years then it will
certainly put us in a position where we
we've already done an action plan but to
that action plan would be added a 20
buffer and if you add a 20 buffer onto
the five-year housing land Supply you'll
see that it is just over five percent
and that and that would take us into a
position where the developers can be
taking us via the appeal process as as I
mentioned earlier to a situation where
building happens where we don't want it
where it's not allocated and certainly
it's not something that I would
recommend in terms of the numbers that
that he's quoted from the Abbott's
Kurzweil Parish Council I think I think
councilor Dawes has got his numbers the
wrong way around the the he was also
quoting the cpre of which I'm a member
the numbers that the cpre think are
reasonable for teambridge are at 540.
that's a figure actually that on the
back of an envelope I've considered to
be looking at the census data about the
right sort of number and would could
agree with that but that's not the case
that we've got at the moment we've got
the the government's numbers only to be
guiding us and currently while microgov
um is suggesting that uh in time to come
that this that number will be advisory
at the moment it's mandatory that's the
way we've got to go
thank you so we'll take councilman
McGregor next please
thank you chair
um one of the excellent points covered
by councilor Taylor there uh was the
housing delivery Target which we've
struggled to achieve over the last three
years and with announcements from four
developers over the last week that the
housing market is slowing down
how will we address that that particular
shortfall that will continue into the uh
probably in the coming two years bearing
in mind that some of the approvals that
we've seen over the last three years
have yet to actually start commencing
building for instance T3 which is rushed
through on the basis that houses would
be delivered by may this year
then we are looking at a situation where
uh housing delivery targets are going to
be failed to be met even on the current
model
and into the new system
um assuming we get a local plan done
that will continue to happen as well so
we may even fall short of our required
540 uh to see the the growth that we see
at the moment across the district
my big problem with the the the letter
and intent from the secretary of state
has articulated by councilor doors is
that this appears to be
superficial at best I believe
um there's a lot of promises about you
know addressing developers but as we
know the the conservatives are funded
heavily by developers having received
over 10 million pounds in the previous
uh elect general election so from that
perspective my concern is that we're
going to be assuming and making our
decisions based on something that won't
actually happen this hasn't gone through
as legislation and I believe that our
guidance will maintain and the plan will
maintain at the current levels which is
I believe 741.
one of the big difficulties that we have
of course is the the repeated Point
articulated by councilor Keeling about
the cost of living crisis is going to
continue to have an impact not only on
the cost of materials for for houses
it's going to push the prices houses
beyond the reach of most of our
residents my question therefore would be
would this Council then be looking to do
become a local Development Corporation
of it in its own right to start
providing homes for local residents
thank you
you can have a shot at answering his
question counselor Taylor or is it
officer material
I think at this point now I I do have a
response in terms of the questions that
uh the in terms of the statement that uh
uh Council councilor McGregor was was
putting in terms of the numbers that uh
that developers uh build and and
certainly at the moment we're in the
where we seem to be entering into a
teeth of a a a pretty much self uh
imposed recession uh which with interest
rates going up that's going to that's
going to have an enormous effect on on
the housing market and
uh my my consideration about the housing
numbers that are handed down for
government it's like pushing on string
at the end of the day it's that no
matter whether it's 741 or the other
number that we heard what was it 18
months ago
1523 that was calculated as being the
right number for teambridge which was
which was laughed out of court
um it's not going to make any difference
at all as to what is built that's a
matter for the market and there is a
market forces
um
mention in the written ministerial
statement again I think it's I think
it's deceptive about what it actually
means it certainly doesn't mean that if
there aren't people to buy the houses
that doesn't mean we shouldn't be giving
further permissions
but I would I would like some further
perhaps details uh from we've got all of
our officers here here at the back of
all of our uh special planning officers
who've done an enormous amount of work
on on our local plan and it'd be great
if we could hear what uh what they have
to say certainly certainly
uh thank you chair I'll pick this one up
if that's okay there's a there's a
couple of points if I may
um can I just come back to the issue of
the housing numbers for the previous
local plan
um that was assessed at independent
examination
um so the alternative ways of doing it
were fully debated and considered by the
inspector and the council's approach was
found to be sound and ultimately adopted
so I think we've demonstrated in the
past of the correct approach in line
with what's expected of US based on
what's required
um to to meet the needs for for the
population
um I'd also identify that
reference to the census is only one part
of assassin housing need you've also got
to look at the household makeup and how
that changes over time so whilst
population may increase or decrease it's
um you know the average number of people
per property and we've seen
consistently over years household size
reduce
and so from that you need
to provide more residents more
properties to meet that need picking up
the point about how we respond
to the slowdown in the markets and what
pressure that might bring and obviously
some of that's outside of our control
It ultimately be to the market to
deliver the housing required what I
would say is the previous local plan had
a mixture of large strategic sites and
smaller sites which helped with the
trajectory of delivering the right
amount of houses per year the smaller
sites have pretty much been built out in
the local plan we are now reliant on the
larger strategic sites which will take a
long time because much more complex as
multiple ownerships and it takes a
longer time to deliver so whilst they're
probably the next within four or five
years time
the development of those schemes will
start to improve our delivery rate we
need to put in place plans for smaller
scale sites that will help with delivery
so the local plan proposes that smaller
more small scale sites so by having a
plan in place will be in Greater control
of help them to bring and try and
address as best we can support delivery
of smaller scale sites to
keep us away from the risks of smaller
schemes coming that aren't allocated in
the local plan
thank you to Neil Blaney one of our
senior officers of the council for
answering that I've got two more
speakers at the moment wanting to speak
and those are councilor Boulevard and
councilor patch I don't know not sure
who has had his name up first but I'll
take Council of batch I think you had
your your name up first
um
thank you chair
um as councilor Dawes has pointed out
other other Progressive councilors are
challenging the official targets that
have been handed down
um or is the our council is not taking
that approach I find it interesting that
both the conservatives and the liberal
Democrats
um seem to be hand-wringing and saying
that there is no scope for challenging
these figures and seem to be almost in a
position about bidding each other as to
how many homes they'd like to build
across team bridge uh be interesting to
see if they um carry on with this as
election time approaches I suspect
there'll be some sort of double talk as
that time does approach but we will see
um I was going to ask questions
regarding the funding that both parties
take from housing developers which might
have some relation to their stance on
house building I thank councilor
McGregor for raising this issue and
pointing to a figure for the
conservatives I wonder if can anybody
from the liberal Democrat Party provide
a figure as to nationally how much their
party receives from housing developers
and whether any talks might be ongoing
with them to receive any more funding as
the next election approaches and I think
about a general election
a council college called my eye to try
and reply to that as leader of the
liberal Democrats I think he's a
chairman as leader of the liberal
Democrats in Cambridge I'm not in
discussion with any developer for
contributions thank you very much well
I'm not
we might be able to get an officer at
the back to answer that difficult one
I'm not a
not going upon
um the suggestion that we haven't
challenged the housing figures
um so just to be clear the current
national planning policy framework does
say that the housing number based on the
standard method is a starting point for
consideration and that exceptional
circumstances could justify a different
approach and that currently considers
two main factors one of those is taking
into account genuine constraints that
includes aspects such as Dartmouth
National Park
um and European Wildlife sites triple
sis and those other sorts of constraints
and those have all been taken into
consideration and we have still been
able to identify through the plan
sufficient land to meet the 741 homes a
year so we do not believe in our
professional view that we have those
exceptional circumstances to Warrant a
different approach both based on that
flexibility
secondly we have undertaken our own
local housing needs assessment this is
part of the evidence base for the local
plan and that does sensitivity check the
standard method formula and it does
conclude that there's insufficient
evidence having looked at all other
different data sets to suggest at this
point in time that an alternative method
for calculating housing need is could be
supported
foreign
leader for the uh lib Dems made that uh
certainly we've not received any money
from developers so thank you
and they appreciate the laughs
in terms of the question I originally
asked it was recognizing that there is
this current state Uh current number
that we obviously required to use but
moving forward reading from the letter
with your permission it says it will be
up to local authorities working with
their communities to determine how many
home homes can actually be built taking
into account and what should be
protected in each area
be that a precious green belt or
national parks the character of an area
or Heritage assets you will also be up
to them to increase the proportion of
affordable housing if they wish my
question was I accept where we are at
the moment but it's moving forward when
will this Council be provided with
information to say how this requirement
is going to be translated given that
over the last four years we're roughly a
thousand homes short of our Target which
implies the 250 affordable homes have
not been delivered and we've seen a 250
increase in the people on the home
housing waiting list over that same
period thank you
I can assist
um obviously the current item is
primarily for information and I think
the cancer I think the question
councilor Boulevard asks is more
pertinent to the next
so I don't I don't think it will
I think it accountable and we'll put
that question in the next session
um you know that may well be but for the
minute we were just simply noting that
we have paused the council meeting from
December to now we had written to uh we
noted the secretary of state statement
with written to the member's apartment
and wanted to lay before members the
responses uh and I think to some extent
uh we should put the recommendations
that are in nine which was basically to
note and move on and then get into the
substantive debate which is primarily a
gender item 10 chairman if you're okay
it's exactly my thoughts because the
recommendation uh on this particular
item is just to note the content of the
report and the appendices and then
proceed to the report on the local plan
consultation so you've answered that so
councilor Cox did want to speak briefly
and then I proposed to take the
recommendation so that we can actually
get into the nitty-gritty as it were
thank you
a bit annoyed I think he's got a lot of
uh Bazaar to for councilor patch to say
that about uh the liberal Democrats I've
just looked on the Electoral commission
uh website and it does not appear to be
uh any donations from developers that I
can see uh in total the liberal
Democrats nationally received a million
and a half pounds
you know councilor um McGregor said
about the it was about in fact 11
million not 10 million that the
conservative party received from
developers or their friends but it
councilman go also mentioned te3
something that Tim with liberal
Democrats really oppose hard earlier on
we had councilor Richard Ash here a
retired geologist a brain the size of a
planet who was going to oppose te3 but
we didn't get
uh councilor Ash what we got was someone
from South Devon Alliance a gentleman
whose contribution to Tim of politics is
to be claimed that Timber District
Council was going to ban 99 ice creams
on the beaches he went and you can walk
don't take my word for it watch watch
the watch the uh opponent of the he used
the uh objector slot on T3 at the
planning committee watch him he
basically said you're going to do this
anywhere goodbye and off we win and this
was a South Devon Alliance supporter
this was the intellectual Brilliance of
the of them doing that so they don't
need to lecture us about opposing house
building
yeah I I don't propose to get into spot
let's let's see if we can go to the
recommended point of it yeah I will take
it councilor Malone yes it'll allow you
to speak
that's the previous member what the hell
he's talking about there's only four
people in the South Devon Alliance and
and it wasn't any of us
always always quoting you actually
um
more lib Dem lies thank you for that
you're alive
I think you've all made your points here
it's getting near an election if we can
just calm it now you I think you've both
you've both made your point so that you
want to make thank you very much now can
I take the recommendation
um please no I propose to move on I'm
sorry and the recommendation is to note
the content of this report and
dependencies and to proceed uh to
consider the report of the local plan
consultation as South in the agenda so
there'll be plenty of time for more of
this banter if you'd like to put it like
that in the next in the next item to
come so can I have a show of hands
please those in support of the
recommendation
foreign
those against the the recommendation
and those abstaining
right thank you very much and that's
avoided uh suspending the meeting and
everything as we managed to move on
thank you very much indeed
uh right I've got to gather my thoughts
and move my own computer on now and all
of that uh right so uh where are we now
we're on to the actual nitty-gritty uh
it's the team bridge proposed submission
local plan uh 2020 to 2040 Pages 165 to
174. are you introducing
you're going to introduce it and then
we're going to have Neil Blaney is going
to talk on it and Michelle luskin has
done a lot of the work and I think
Michelle luscom's one of the officers
underneath her is going to have a word
as well so the the we'll get into the
nitty-gritty of this before we have a
comfort break I'm sure thank you carry
on councilor Taylor thank you very much
Mr chairman members the development of a
new local plan for Tunbridge which began
in 2017 has today reached an important
Milestone new planning policies
concerning how future development is
managed along with new site allocations
for where homes employment premises and
wind turbines can be built are now ready
for the final stage of public
consultation prior to examination
as I have noted in the forward of our
new local plan document at appendix a I
firmly believe this is an ambitious
forward-looking new local plan that will
help deliver better and more
environmentally sustainable development
in our district over the next two
decades
at the top of the new local plan to-do
list has been making sure that people
have access to the homes jobs green
spaces and services that they need while
reducing also our carbon footprint and
improving energy
uh resilience in doing so we must also
currently meet our government's Target
for house building and of course
conserve and wherever possible enhance
our very special and valued environments
we are confident our plans do just this
it includes tougher policies to help
fight climate change and also stronger
support for our environment it
identifies enough land for new homes to
be built and for employment
opportunities to flourish it tasks
developers with designing beautiful
places building more genuinely
affordable homes and to contribute to
the infrastructure that our growing
communities need
in our search for new development we
have been directed by three guiding
principles taking every opportunity to
use Brownfield sites first including
Redevelopment and regeneration within
our town centers
locating most of our new homes where
they will be close to jobs services and
sustainable transport routes
and seeking out smaller sites for
housing in larger villages to help
sustain essential local services and
Facilities
this plan is the result of all these
wide-ranging considerations brought
together by a cross-party working group
of elected members and a dedicated
officer planning team
their continual efforts deserve our
thanks as together they have brought
forward a plan which will raise the
standards of development enable housing
and employment for the benefit of our
families and future generations and
Safeguard the special characteristics
and biodiversity of our district
I would also like to take this
opportunity to thank on behalf of the
council those many organizations and
members of the public who have already
responded to our previous local planned
consultations
the passion people have shown for their
communities and their local environment
has been remarkable with only with over
7 000 responses received covering a wide
a wide range of comments and views
these comments have all been read and
collated under appendix f
and will have done much to inform the
final draft of the new local plan
Mr chairman as you and our members will
know there is a huge amount of very
interesting and absorbing detail in the
local plan
and its supporting documents which I'm
sure the public will already be diving
into to read
I'm sure also that the public and many
other organizations will be Keen to have
their say and I would certainly
encourage as many people as possible to
take part in this final consultation
prior to the plan going to inspection
I would therefore like to propose Mr
chairman that further to the
considerations of the documents we have
before us today we move recommendations
one to eight as set out
and move recommendation nine which
Begins by stating following consultation
submit the proposed local plan
2020-2040 and Associated documents to
the Secretary of State for the
Department of leveling up housing and
communities to begin proceedings for
public examination with the additional
wording that this will include granting
delegated authority to the head of place
and Commercial Services in consultation
with the executive member for planning
and the chair of the local plan working
group to recommend minor modifications
to the inspector prior to submission
while any major modifications will be
referred to for Council
and to propose also finally an
additional recommendation which we heard
a little from uh from Michelle earlier
recommendation 10
subject to the current proposed changes
in to the National planning policy
framework coming into effect which
relates specifically to housing
requirements becoming advisory
the council commits to undertake a
review of The District's housing needs
immediately following adoption of the
2020-2040 local plan which takes into
account forthcoming census based
household and population projections and
if a lower housing requirement is
identified proceed with an urgent
partial review of the plan which
reflects a lower housing needs Target Mr
chairman members thank you that's
seconded by Council
right before we opened it up to debate
we're going to hear more from Neil
Blaney and then Michelle
he's going straight to me thank you yeah
okay I'm not going to comment on the
detail of the plan
um as I understand we'll be going
through that section by section in due
course but I just wanted to set out some
procedural matters
the local Plan before you is the
regulation 19 version of the plan so
this means that it's the final draft and
it's the version that we are agreeing to
submit to the Secretary of State
following consultation
there is scope following the
consultation to consider any comments to
the plan and recommend modifications to
the inspector examining the plan if we
consider that to be appropriate
the local plan 2020-2040 is set out in
two parts
part one
part one contains a set of policies
which manage how development takes place
and part two contains site allocations
for new homes employment premises Gypsy
and traveler sites and wind turbines
all local authorities are required to
have an up-to-date local plan
as plans become out of date there are
greater risks and government imposed
penalties these are all set out in
section 5c of the report
as you'll already be aware from the
previous report there are significant
benefits to us reaching the regulation
19 stage of consultation on the plan
alongside it being a significant step in
updating the current local plan
which is now several years old this
relates to us securing a more favorable
housing land Supply land Supply position
while we take the plan through
examination
alongside the plan there are various
supporting documents and the policies
map with the exception exception of
appendix e these are legally required to
be prepared and consulted on as part of
the plan
appendix e is the giraffe Community
infrastructure Levy charging schedule
which sets the rates payable for new
developments towards new infrastructure
in the district
the local plan covers the period from
2020 to 2040. a lot of the evidence that
supports the plan forecasts change and
development requirements up to that date
and Beyond in some cases this allows us
to set policies policies which are fit
to meet future demands as well as
respond to the issues that we want to
address at the moment
within this 20-year plan period we are
making provision for 15 years worth of
housing land Supply
National policy requires us to ensure
that we identify sufficient land for the
first 10 years of the plan and wherever
possible for years 11 to 15.
the amount of housing should meet our
objectively assessed need which should
be calculated using the standard method
unless exceptional circumstances justify
an alternative approach
as has already been discussed such
circumstances have been examined and are
considered not to apply to team bridge
at this time
as such the district's housing
requirement stands at 741 homes a year
totaling 11 856 homes over 15 years
we are also required to provide a 20
buffer because of our recent Trends in
under delivery of housing
the plan therefore makes provision for
12 489 homes which is set out in policy
H1 on pages 59 and 60 of uh of appendix
a which is the plan and that enables us
to have 15 years worth of housing from
the point at which we anticipate
adopting the plan which we hope will be
early 2024
the plan before you is the culmination
of four rounds of consultation extensive
evidence and continued liaison with the
local plan working group
the site allocations within the plan
have been proposed on the basis that
they meet the preferred distribution of
development which has been developed
with the local plan working group and
has been consulted on
this distribution is based on firstly
prioritizing Brownfield development
allocating most development close to
jobs homes and services and public and
job services and public transport
and supporting the sustainability of
Village services with proportional
levels of development
the site assessment themselves have
involved detailed site investigations
environmental assessments and site
visits to which all Ward members were
invited to attend
potential potential site options were
then refined through discussions with
the local plan working group
importantly the decision has been taken
to not allocate in settlements simply
for the sake of allocating in a
particular location
increasingly potential development sites
are becoming more and more constrained
by their physical attributes and or
increasing distance away from town or
Village centers and services
this means that it isn't always possible
to locate new development in a
particular settlement which might
otherwise appear to be a good
sustainable location this is
particularly the case at present with
timoth and dawlish
we have consulted with infrastructure
providers and statutory consultees
including historic England the
environment agency National highways
Natural England the NHS and Southwest
water throughout the preparation of this
plan and have included any requirements
or responded to any concerns raised by
them wherever possible and relevant
you will see that site-specific
requirements are included within
individual allocation policies and the
overall infrastructure requirements are
set out in policy gp7 including a per
dwelling contribution towards NHS
infrastructure
the plan is presented to you as a
document which officers consider to be
sound and on this basis it is
recommended on this basis recommended
that it and its supporting documents are
published for consultation from the 23rd
of January to the 20th to the 23rd of
January to the 13th of March 2023
followed by submission to the Secretary
of State for leveling up housing and
communities
so that's all for me at the moment
obviously I'm happy to take questions
um but could I please invite the chair
to invite councilor Goodman Bradbury to
speak on behalf of the local plan
working group
yes indeed councilman Goodman Bradley
look forward to hearing from you thank
you for your permission
um I just have a few words just to to
add the local plan working group has
offered a way for members from all
across the political divide in the
council to have a say on the progress of
the plan
we started meeting on the 21st of
October 2019 and have met many times
since I'm not going to list them
hopefully members have read all of the
details and particularly the background
paper number three this gives all the
full details
we last met as an extraordinary local
plan working group on the 15th of
December 2022 regarding the right
honorable Michael gove's planning
reforms in his statement much has been
said about that already the working
group has been an open and productive
Forum that has allowed everyone
of the group and other members to have
their say and question the process the
policy and discuss these with other
members and the officers as the current
chair I would like to say a few thank
yous please particularly to the previous
chair Mike Haynes for his work on the
Healer process
and the officers for their ongoing work
and support and all of the members
engagement on this process thank you
thank you very much indeed
so we're now going to get into the
nitty-gritty of how I handle this I
think really
I've got the local plan obviously in
front of me some some of you have
probably got it on online and what have
you and I propose I think the best thing
to go through it is is literally if you
want to speak on it we'll go through
each sections there's I mean here are
the various sections general policies
one climate change two design and
well-being three economy four homes Five
environment six site allocations are
seven and that morphs into eight Newton
Abbott and King State and garden
Community policies and allocations
Nine's the edge of Exeter tennis coastal
towns 11 rural towns and B 12 is
Villages so I think the best thing I can
do is start at the beginning and then
you catch my eye if you want to speak on
that do you do I see a sort of not
general knowledge of approval does that
make sense to to members to try and do
it does that make sense to you councilor
Taylor would you like me to handle it
that way
right okay so we'll have a we're going
into the plan don't forget it's a just a
bit of background for myself in the
chair it's a hundred and uh 75 pages
long as you as you realize from members
of viewing this on on YouTube and you'll
see that uh
um I made some notes here that Newton
Abbott and King Stephen Garden Community
is where 37 of the homes are proposed to
to be built the edge of extra 46 coastal
towns five Villages 12 and that includes
employment 55 Newton Abbot edge of extra
is 31
um Coastal and Rural towns five percent
Villages nine percent
uh and uh that's a total introduced of
uh four thousand five hundred and sixty
new homes are allocated uh in in this
plan okay so that sets the background
for it I think so uh has has anybody
wants to speak on the general policy is
in the plan uh Pages 14 to 24. so
anybody you want to have a go counselor
Swain like to speak on that
thank you chair
um I do have General comments to make
about the plan as well yes presumably
we're going to take those at the end ah
yes I think that makes sense
I won't take time now thanking the
officers for the work and so forth yes
but in the general policies I do want to
draw attention to
um the comments about so in our area in
the community that I serve
um in a waste landfill sites are a very
large substantial issue for the
community and there is an issue that
developers produce as much waste as they
like Devon feels that Devon County feels
the need to meet the demand for landfill
sites and there doesn't appear to be any
limitation to how much this can go on
um and in the new plan there are
specific wording in general policy one I
think it is sorry General policy one I
think it is there's specific wording
about developers minimizing the export
of waste and accommodating waste
material on site it's a very subtle
change but for the first time we can
actually see something concrete which
says developers need to minimize this
damaging practice thank you very much
does anybody else want to speak on
general policies Pages 14 to 24.
right we'll move to
your portfolio holder isn't it counselor
hook here and really you know climate
change too is anybody want to speak on
that that's pages 27-38
no fun make sure you catch my eye if you
do
did catch my eye in the end thank you
thank you chair
um just um a general Point I've been
having problems with my laptop and I
can't actually access it online is there
a hard copy available at the moment or
otherwise can somebody share the
password for the Wi-Fi to get in on this
um the local network
someone from the back has come forward
kindly to give you what you want
got what you want
well done
right
um
counselor hook
here microphone here for me
thank you chair I was waiting to see if
others made comments before I made some
comments yeah I I just wanted to
um like again it's I'm not sure where
it's appropriate to make General
comments but why not also to um credit
the work of the local plan working group
um as has already been said cross-party
group of members we've been meeting for
the last two or three years regularly to
discuss all aspects of the local plan
the process how consultations are
carried out the results of those
consultations
um the policies and the sites in quite
considerable detail it's obviously an
Advisory Group not a decision-making
body
um but I feel it worked well
um and I feel that collectively we have
pushed policies as far as we possibly
can with reference to what other
councils around the country are doing in
all the broad areas of
um topics
um but personally my my area of climate
change I I feel we've pushed as far as
we can on the policies
um where where it maybe hasn't gone as
far as maybe I and possibly someone from
act action on climate in teambridge
would feel it is gone I think we through
the working group have understood why it
hasn't been able to go that far and
that's usually because of national
planning policy constraints or other
legislation that means we cannot go that
far but I feel we really have pushed as
far as we can the policies we have now
for addressing climate change in our
district are so significantly better
than where we are with our existing
Miracle plan and that's why one of the
reasons one of the many very good
reasons why we must continue down the
path of adopting our local plan
um you know there are I don't agree with
the housing numbers as they are I could
say a lot on that but the outline within
the report we've just had and and the
local plan are some very good reasons
why we do need to continue
um to adoption and adopting these
policies on climate change is is top of
the list for me thank you
well if I can just say thank you for all
the hard work you've done on it too from
the chat uh
you know if we can move on then to
commenting on um oh cancel the doors now
is that sorry I'm sorry Richard I didn't
see you I know you didn't have a line of
sight so it's okay uh I I sort of
reinforced but probably doubled down uh
on what a lot of uh councilor hook just
said uh the policies are better uh but
they're nowhere near as good as as they
should they should be and if we speak
sort of metaphorically our house is on
fire and and now isn't the time for us
to say we're constrained by a national
planning policy now is the time to
to do what extension Rebellion are doing
and actually take a stand and do
something that that is really sort of uh
forward-thinking and Progressive uh I
know councilor uh Taylor said we are a
regressive Council we're Progressive in
in words and not not in actions
um the greatest thing that would have
had an impact would have been reviewing
the the housing targets I know councilor
hook said she'd prefer that they were
less well uh taking some actions on that
as a member of the executive would have
been slightly more helpful uh the cpre
did say a
540 houses for the district so that's a
reduction of 200 per year that would
have had a huge huge impact so um so
it's sort of disappointing that the the
the the the the group that sat I sat on
the uh
um the the
um planning uh with the working group
for the for the local plan almost as a
conscientious objective but at least
seeing how the process actually run
and I note
Michelle's comments that that within the
constraints that they they were able to
deliver the 700 houses I mean those
constraints are if you shoehorn a
development in between a European
protected site and a triple sa and
impact on on those areas then you
probably can build those houses uh but
that but that isn't really what what a
progressive Council should be doing we
we should have been making a stand we
should have made a stand before I was
elected we should have made a stand when
when we were elected and when we raised
the questions and we shouldn't have been
put through standards complaints and and
smeared as counselors for for
questioning the housing housing numbers
so uh the whole process is is
disappointing there seems to be a lot of
platitudes uh and and noises come in
like out the councils but no
particularly good solid actions so uh
that's my thought for for wearer and
climate change thank you
you want to come back councilor Taylor I
I do uh thank you very much chair I'm
very pleased actually that uh that
councilor Dawes is at least right on one
thing he now has corrected himself and
the cpre number is 540 and not the 440
but she stated stated earlier was
similar to the Abbott's Kurzweil number
um but I don't really want to get
involved with him on a bum fight about
about it about who is a Progressive
Progressive Council who isn't I believe
our our our
policies are very Progressive I think
we've proved that from declaring a
climate emergency from 2025 and 2019 and
if you look at the
more importantly if you look at the
policy that we've got in front of us
today on page 28 at B major residential
schemes for 10 or more houses from plan
adoption to the 31st of uh from planet
adoption to the 31st of from the 1st of
January I should say 2025 achieved Net
Zero carbon development via a minimum 75
reduction in carbon and Emissions
against part L of the building raised to
2013 to be achieved through a reduction
in energy consumption consumption via a
fabric first approach which we promote
the remaining reductions in carbon
emissions would be achieved through top
up by a combination of fabric
improvements on-site renewable energy
generation or if necessary through
equivalent Financial contributions to an
agreed teambridge-approved carbon
offsetting fund I think this local plan
in terms of our environmental
credentials credentials and the
progressive nature of this of this
Authority speak for themselves
I'm commenting on on trying to keep it
to uh climate change Pages 27 to 20 38
so councilor Swain then it'll be
councilor Hawking thank you
thank you Chad um I want the second the
support for the climate change chapter
um last year I took part in a task and
finish group to look at timbridge's
progress with the climate emergency one
of the activities there was a direct
policy by policy comparison of the new
and the former local plan
um and having compared it sentence by
sentence it's hugely improved in effect
there's a chapter on climate change here
where there was a policy before
um so I absolutely welcome that
um chair I'm very conscious reading the
room that we seem to all be itching to
talk about housing numbers might I
propose that we raise that next and then
proceed to the section by section well I
I would like to go through it section by
section just follow it along if I may so
I'm going to decline because I suggest
that we don't talk about housing numbers
yeah
there's Council Hocking at the back next
and then it's councilor McGregor
cheers thank you uh chairman mine is on
climate change and it's um cc4 which is
sustainable uh transport we all have to
welcome sustainable transport I'm sure
um my question is what more Powers as
this this Council got that's going to
actually bring all this to fruition
bearing in mind that all the all the
buildings so far are being done around
it now but the sustainable transport has
failed there's not even a proper link
between Hill Park and the Town Center
where you can walk safely and so what
more powers
does this new plan give this Council to
make sure that this is done not halfway
through a development but before the
development starts so the links are
there so that when the people move into
their new houses they have already got
the links there because I think it's
very important that those links are
there thank you
yeah Neil I was hoping that I was
looking towards officers Neil Blaney
okay uh yeah I'll I'll pick up the
response initially and then Michelle
will come back a little bit more
um
what what we do through this plan
um I I guess I'll pick up the hill Park
but to start with actually um because
that's a good example of the risks we
Face Hill Park was allowed on appeal
initially and some of the links between
that development and the routes into the
town weren't ideal and what you're
seeing now with the development that's
coming forward is proper cycle
infrastructure being put in place so
you'll see if as you go along ashburton
roads for example the foot path has been
widened by having these plans and
looking longer term we start to look
more strategically at those networks and
connections so we've got the local cycle
and walking plan for Newton Abbott for
example but as part of development we
can request more strategic thinking
about how these links are going to
connect up so the plans the larger
allocations and what will come through
in this plan will include not only the
infrastructure on site for allowing the
better walking and cycling opportunities
but then strategic links around so
there's a lot that's already been
implemented as you look along the stove
way you look at the plans that we're
trying to bring forward for the teen
Estuary Trail which is very high
priority and then there's the work going
forward on Lincoln Torbay to Newton Abba
for example so past those those plans
are based on what came from the last
local plan this this plan includes more
of the same so that's part of the
development as it comes forward
development management can negotiate how
that's going to work and bring that
forward then there's the financial
contributions that are made from
development which play towards the
infrastructure so there's off-site
requirements that comes through this as
well so there's good strong relationship
we've got with the County Council we've
got the plans in place to implement the
local plant helps to do that and and I
think you know Hill Park should be a
lesson that if we aren't careful and
we're reliant on schemes by appeal you
don't get the Strategic link up between
it all so that's how that's going to
work moving forward and I think there's
significant power in that
um that you know we don't approve
schemes as an authority unless we're
comfortable that the impact of this is
acceptable that there is a plan in place
for more sustainable forms of transport
and that all development is contributing
to The Wider infrastructure improvements
Michelle now
thank you chair
um yeah just to
what Neil has said
um I think the rhetoric is Shifting
um definitely from central government
all the way down now in that the
emphasis is now on sustainable and
active transport not on Building New
Roads so there's nothing in the plan for
any new roads to be built other than
within the developments themselves so I
think that's a really key point to make
and we're working closely with Devon
County Council and their active
transport team to ensure that the new
developments do prioritize low traffic
neighborhoods wherever possible and all
active and sustainable travel links as
well
um just um I would draw your attention
on page 22 in gp7
um 0.7 there's a paragraph been included
within that policy that was discussed
and put forward by the local plan
working group and developed with them
and I'll just read it out so it's this
is our infrastructure policy it says
whilst recognizing potential for
development viability considerations
ensure that new development is provided
with appropriate infrastructure as early
in the development as possible
connections to existing footpaths and
cycleways will be delivered prior to or
alongside the first occupation active
travel links to potential long-term
future development sites will be
safeguarded
and that was directly in response to
issues that we understand we're having
at the moment
I think I hope that's answered and I
missed going around the room I miss
people here I think you were next uh
councilman McGregor is next year sorry
councilman gray carry on
thank you chair
um and and I've got two points to raise
first of all is the the sustainable uh
travel element of it
as a small district with heavy rural
setting we have roads that have had
surface
existing for around about 25 years and
the life extension of that is 40 years
by government policy
the problem with extending life of of
Road surfaces when you're actually
increasing the traffic is that it
doesn't last and we're seeing increasing
damage to Road surfaces across the
district in fact on the route in today
on the a379 there was at least six brand
new potholes along that stretch of road
between teignmouth and
and the uh the roundabout at the Dual
carriageway so you know the whilst the
government policy is not to put in New
Roads we should be expecting
um increased investment in the current
road system that we do have particularly
for safety of pedestrians safety of
cyclists and motorcyclists who are
having to weave round potholes in the
road
and that's that's the first element to
it the second element is uh on the
climate change and you know I remember
um not that long ago an excellent motion
came through from councilor hook
councilor Jackie hook
on Ocean cleanliness now I know that
Southwest water are a statutory
Consulting in the local plan because
they provide water and wastewater
provision and chair you'll be you'll be
um on board with this I'm sure is that
Southwest water are failing even to
maintain a level of disposal without
releases into the estuaries and
waterways of this District
I have seen no evidence from Southwest
water to say that they actually have a
plan in place to prevent that
of what their recommendation is that
this planning Authority and all planning
authorities across the country
have regular ongoing detailed
consultation meetings with their
providers in their areas to ensure
that waste water and water supply is
sustainable and manageable and that
releases into the system and are
minimized we're not seeing that
I also note that then the statutory
consultation details almost every single
site for Southwest water was at risk of
over capacity already and again I see
nothing in the local plan that addresses
that fact and requires Southwest water
to improve their provision
that is a real concern in an area
particularly you know and I was looking
at this a few days ago
I think the teen Estuary particularly is
an area of outstanding natural beauty
that is unrecognized of course by
Natural England but it is a phenomenal
area it has sea seafood fishing
businesses working in that area it has a
very valuable tourist industry based
around a visitor industry based around
people coming down to tinmouth
and if we're not addressing situations
like that then we are going to put
businesses and tourism at risk
the blue flag I believe is already
perhaps been lost at one of the beaches
that we we have as a as a district
and that is a real concern as well so
from my perspective
we need to see more in the plan about
what we're doing about Southwest Waters
inability and failures to provide a
service as it currently stands before we
start building new infrastructure
thank you
right before I move to anybody else what
I what I'm trying to do
yeah go on
uh thank you chair
um yeah so as I sort of mentioned
earlier we have been liaising with
Southwest water
um as part of the preparation of the
plan I don't know whether I know some of
my senior officers have been involved in
meetings with Southwest water so if they
do want to speak
um maybe I could invite them through the
chair to um to speak
oh yeah okay um so but just before I
hand over to Katie
um
just to sort of be clear that we can't
um enforce or you know make policies for
things that are outside the scope of new
development so we can't deal with
necessarily the existing issues that
take place but we do have relevant
policies in the plan that address the
the new development and the Southwest
water requirements
um in terms of what they've fed back to
us
um they have informed us of all of the
sewage and Wastewater Network
requirements within all areas of the
district wherever we're proposing
development
um and this will be included within the
infrastructure delivery plan which will
be published as part of the consultation
as background
um or as supporting information
um they require all new developments to
pay an infrastructure charge and this
covers the cost of the extra Demand on
the network and all developments were
also required to put in place
sustainable Drainage Systems so that's a
summary and hopefully
um if it's okay I'll pass over to Katie
to provide you with a bit more detail
about the discussions
thank you Michelle I don't actually
think I've got anything to add to what
you've just said
huh
thank you thank you yeah all right yeah
I'm conscious members that look
we're going through this uh if you like
item by item and we're on climate change
what I'm really looking to tease out of
you at the end of all this uh if you
want to change anything on climate
change you've got to come forward you
know with an amendment I think is is to
anything it's otherwise what we're
looking to do is let this document go
forward for consultation therefore we're
having a chat about it and if you want
to change anything you've got to put it
I believe you've got to put an amendment
up I only said that in mind so I'll
leave you leave members to ponder on
that if we can leave climate change now
and go on to the third one design and
well-being has anybody got anything uh
to say on pages 41 to 44 on uh design
and well-being that's in the plan we
don't want to be changing it now
that's why that's why you had the brief
chair earlier yeah well I do understand
I do understand that we I'm conscious
that we're not going to filibust this
out of time where they sit down in
America and talk and talk it all out of
time and what have you I do want to get
home tonight like everybody but anyway
right we would I'm still going to stick
to that
counselor
thank you Charlie I had to put my hand
yes yes yeah I know you did yes yes yeah
I did yeah yeah thank you
um yeah I just wanted to just say a
little bit sorry it's a general comment
um but about
um you know the idea of building houses
how many houses you build and the impact
that has on climate change in our
district nationally or internationally
um so to me the really important thing
to think about is that
um
the biggest
impact on carbon emissions is how we
travel around in our lives so transport
and how we heat our homes those are the
two most significant factors
um so if you look at it that way people
can live in a house they might live in
team bridge one of our new houses but
they're going to live somewhere and what
we've got to ensure collectively as a
nation is that the houses we build for
the people of this country whether
they're in teambridge or somewhere else
on the assumption that people will be
living in a house somewhere is that we
collectively ensure that we enable
people to travel as sustainably as
possible minimizing the use of the car
by the way we locate development and the
infrastructure we put in for sustainable
and active travel and then how we build
those homes so that they are extremely
energy efficient and any surplus heating
is done non-fossil fuel heating now that
is what this plan achieves so we are
going to locate houses where hopefully
people will be able to maximize their
use of sustainable and active travel and
we have in in here the ability to
achieve highly energy efficient housing
with non-fossil fuel Heating and that's
what we will demand through the policies
of this plan and that is the way I think
we need to think of it these houses will
exist somewhere let's make sure the ones
we build in teambridge are top quality
thank you
thank you very much
so can I can I move Beyond then uh is
there anybody that actually wants to
comment on who
Council doors
yeah just coming back on that point on
uh climate change impact and I think you
missed food of that this food production
and consumption uh but the uh what's
missing in this plan then in in that
instance and I'd agree with you in terms
of uh the most efficient housing is uh
if you get the train through Taunton
you'll see uh sort of multiple uh
occupancy developments uh the three
four-story High uh blocks of flats are
looking very tidy around the station
what's missing out this plan is uh where
are those around uh new Nabbit train
station why why is this just predicated
with uh loss of Greenfield sites once
more uh with the obvious loss of those
Green Fields as carbon sings
Misha
Council Taylor then
thank you Chad I think what you doors is
showing that he hasn't been looking at
the documents again but there is
actually a site for 150 houses uh in uh
for Ford close before yep uh just next
to the station
do you want to come back counselor doors
very quickly
okay
can I just add yeah go on with Michelle
sorry I didn't say uh yeah um obviously
councilor Taylor is correct we have got
an allocation
um at Ford close for 150 units I do
expect those to probably be
um Apartments
um relatively high density there
um other options obviously in the Town
Center
um and we'll come on to later on have
been thoroughly explored but you know we
do have significant areas of
um very high flood risk within the Town
Center which limits our opportunities
for developing there
again that answers that so can I can I
pass beyond climate change and then
we've got to page 38 now I know
yes counselor Goodman Bradley not
Council good for him
councilor Bradford
thank you chair I just wanted to
um disagree with councilor hook one of
the biggest climate change problems is
what we put on our plate
how we Farm our animals
um it's it's worse than
um the reason she gave thank you
right
oh she's hanging the microphone back
anybody else don't listen can I go
beyond this now
all right comment on design and
well-being now
oh sorry counselor again
trying to move the meeting on sorry well
I can't leave that there can I but um I
I believe she's incorrect it's transport
and heating that is top and probably
food production and what we put on our
plate probably is third
um but
um
yeah as far as the plan is dealing with
those aspects I'd like to think
the transformation of the agricultural
system isn't properly within the remit
of the local plan but um yeah
right can I move on then to Pages 41 to
uh to 44 which is design and well-being
oh councilor Bradford you're not you
want to say come back on that comment
dear
Keith it is within the remap because
we're ripping up all the fields thank
you okay well let's move on now uh as I
said to cancer to design and well-being
anybody want to comment on pages 41 to
44.
right well let's move on to the fourth
item there which is the economy uh
which is pages 47-58
right
item five is homes which is Pages 59 to
88 in the plan
item six is Ian oh councilor Wrigley
uh thank you chair I'd just like to draw
council's attention to the affordable
homes policy which is focusing on social
rent now unfortunately we have to
provide 25 percent of those affordable
homes will be going to the government's
first home scheme which is another
ridiculous scheme that the government's
put in place which really won't help our
residents very much but the homes being
provided for social rent certainly will
thank you
now we're on to a six which is the
environment Pages 89
to 115.
okay
and we're getting into the nitty-gritty
which is what comes to Swain requested I
believe we're getting to the site
allocations now which is good uh site
allocations is uh item seven and it's
it's the it starts off with um
item eight is the subheading Newton
Abbott and Kingston Garden Community
policies and allocations pages 122.
to 142 has anybody got any any comments
that they want to make on that
thank you
uh this was all fairly unanimous wasn't
it at the uh the local plan working
group so that's good to know that we're
moving on uh nine is the edge of exetera
and people may want to comment on that
as significant housings going in these
two places one we've just passed which
is the Newton Newton Abbot one or just
uh and we're going to the edge of Acts
the councilor Swain which is Pages 145
to 153.
thank you chair
um edge of extra is very much my area
and yes the developments scheduled in
here are extremely large
um so I feel I should comment yes indeed
that Mark and Simon in particular is 900
homes it is huge
um the community are not keen on this
site and I have spoken against it at
every opportunity in supporting the
community with that view
um significant concerns have been raised
about travel and the road Network in the
area which are serious problems uh to a
large extent those have been addressed I
recognize that but there continues to be
concerned about areas like alphington
Road
um whilst I appreciate we're not editing
the plan on a case-by-case basis I do
want to be on note that I do continue to
have serious concerns about the site
thank you thank you very much indeed uh
if anybody else wanted to speak on the
edge of Exeter no
right 10 is we're doing very well now we
are getting a move on we're just glad to
see
um tennis coastal towns
um one page 156 any anybody commenting
on that pretty well timoth and Doris are
left alone from from that which you've
heard
uh the um the not that sites that are
not being allocated no you're fine
counselor McGregor
thank you chair
um in in terms of the the the fact that
tinmouth and dollish have been excluded
from the the site allocations and I I
you know I was there for some of the
discussions around reasons why
uh but the one thing that does concern
me about that of course is when you talk
about sustainable travel across the
district Tidmouth has a railway station
dawlish has a railway station they're
well serviced by buses uh from Torquay
right through to Exeter from Newton
Abbott through to Exeter
um from Newton Abbott through to Torquay
via that that route
um and it does concern me that when we
talk about sustainable travel that we've
ignored a massive elephant in the room
with timoth and dawlish being on
commuter routes
um for those for those people wishing to
travel in either direction
uh and I think that is an opportunity
missed thank you
okay
so oh there's a hand up over there
Council councilor Cox
timoth cannot take any more development
uh our infrastructure cannot deal with
it in fact uh Timber's burst out of its
boundaries uh my parents live in what I
call Dot dawlish occupied Timber they
have a timoth address tq14 8 you know
they have a team of telephone number
when we used to have telephone numbers
that were down to towns uh all things
Timber but they technically live in the
Parish of dawlish you know we burst our
we've burst our boundaries we can't take
any more may have a railway station
thank God but
um uh we we cannot take any more housing
okay
10 is uh coastal towns and one number
one five six uh which is got the Langdon
Business Park in it I don't think
anybody wants to speak on that at the
moment so right rural towns is 11. Pages
158 to 160. uh that's Bobby Tracy and
chudley isn't it anybody comment want to
comment on that is being in the plan
no we're all right on haven't seen any
house no right we're doing well here so
we're on to uh to find a bit of the plan
which is Villages which are only taking
what is it five percent no 12 percent of
the houses which is uh Pages 162 to 175
and there'll be Council of patch on that
thank you
thank you chair
um I'd just like to reference a comment
um from Michelle a short while ago about
the constraints to development in Newton
Abbott around
floodplain issues and the risk of
flooding and just to note that
um one of the significant developments
in liverton
um does actually mention in the local
plan the risk of flooding from the
liverton brook
I'm not totally convinced having seen
the flooding in that area what three
three years or so ago three four years
ago that that is a robust site for
housing I'd just like to note that and
it'll be interesting to see what comes
back from the consultation whether
anybody looks at that more closely I I
know that going back about it was three
or four years ago there was a huge
flooding in that area including the main
road which will go past or very close to
that development
um so I just wanted to want to flag that
really at this stage
uh okay who was counselor McGregor
wasn't it over there
thank you chair
um by Ward's Bishop Stanton
um the
plan has two sites allocated
um both of which are outside the
settlement limit so bursting out uh to
to take uh councilor Cox's Point
um
both sides present a highway safety
issue for
um pedestrians and cyclists getting into
the town
the proposed route from one of the sites
was through lawn end which is the the
local park but it still takes
pedestrians onto narrow unpaved
um roadways
um and then out onto the the road
without Pavements to walk on
um so from that perspective
um we still have a situation where we
have two sites where highway safety is a
concern now one of the big things that
I've noticed in planning whenever we get
a planning application coming to the
planning committee is that oh it's
allocated in the um in the local plan so
therefore it must have been checked well
here we are sitting talking about two
sites which I've highlighted have a
highway safety issue one of which was
rejected for highway safety issues
although it has to be said the highway
safety issue notation that the rejection
had was actually not what was discussed
at the committee meeting which is very
disappointing to find out that out after
the fact
the situation remains we're talking
about two sites with no increase in
um infrastructure being talked about
Beyond Psychopaths and Pavements uh foot
routes but we're talking about foot
routes that take people through a
dangerous section of roadway which is
exactly the same problem that Baker's
yard was rejected on
last year
now from my perspective we shouldn't be
putting sites onto the local plan where
there is a highway safety issue
and where I was promised prior to this
actual document that I would see
alternative workups on opportunities to
make those routes safe and I have seen
nothing so far on that basis alone I
cannot
I cannot
back this local plan I cannot vote for
it thank you very much chair
I'd like officer comment on that if I'm
here with it
try and answer it yeah uh thank you very
much chair
um so in terms of the assessment of
these sites they have all been looked at
by the highways officers at Devon County
Council and the infrastructure
requirements that are included within
the policy have been agreed with them
from their perspective as a highway
Authority these developments um can be
delivered in a safe and accessible way
in terms of Baker's yard being refused
previously on Highway grounds that is
correct as I understand it however the
um what the the combination of the two
sites enable is for Baker's yard which
is a redundant Brownfield site to come
forward and forward Elaine the the other
allocation provides that safe pedestrian
access route and facilitate a safe
pedestrian routes through from baker's
yard to the rest of the village in terms
of of when it comes out into the village
and the lack of Pavements this is no
different from many of the other
villagers that we've got in the district
but they have you know relatively low
low speed low level traffic within those
and again have been
um these have been agreed with the
highway Authority
um the work that councilor McGregor has
spoken about in terms of those
pedestrian routes
I have responded to those
in an email that he um sent to Phil
shears and responded on the basis of the
update with those and the concept plan
has been updated to reflect those
concerns and is provided in appendix two
I think uh sorry no appendix five
um
uh of the of the plan which
um is part of of all your documentation
today so
um if you would like to see it we
probably can get it up on the screen but
it it is there as part of the council
documents um appendix 5 to appendix a
um apologies for the difficulties with
navigating all of this but there's a lot
of information
you want to come back on the answer
didn't you
thank you chair um in terms of Baker's
yard Baker's yard was refused on the
basis of Devon highways own advice they
objected to that particular plan coming
through now I appreciate that Michelle
has mentioned that the combination of
the sites but that still presents us
with taking people down away from the
the village in a circuitous route and
then back up to the main road which
nobody's going to use so there's going
to be taking people out onto an unsafe
highway there is nowhere to stand out of
the way when traffic is coming down that
lane that is the fact of the matter and
it's unlikely that on a single site
review of Baker's yard which is likely
to happen first anyway because it is
ready
um in terms of
you know the work that needs to be done
that that site can be can be approved
there is also no safe route for people
coming out of Baker's yard or for
delaying site to arrive at a bus stop
safely to Newton Abbott without walking
a mile out of their way
and that is again another part of the
refusal that should have been noted by
the planning committee when the refusal
Baker's yard was uh put through but they
failed to note that on the decision
notice which is actually just very
disappointing to see that actually
excluded and I'm sure councilor Hayne
will recall that
um
that that particular meeting because he
did narrow it down to the specifics
around the highway safety
um so I'm still at the position where
I'm unable to support
yeah I'm sure the officer will respond
on that and you've probably got a chance
to comment on this in the consultation
haven't you so uh we're getting it let's
hear from Michelle thank you well that's
from me um from Neil yeah so paragraph
12.14 on page 164 says that it's likely
to be phased at this Baker's yard will
come forward after for the lane uh the
other point I would make is that
obviously Devon County you've been
consulted on all of the sites they are
supportive of the policies are set out
and the policies set out what needs to
be in place to ensure that we're
satisfied that it can be delivered and
delivered safely and so the proposal
comes forward that we consider doesn't
meet that
um the policy allows us to refuse that
so that's the thing to be mindful of is
that the policies uh drafted to take all
of those concerns into account
right thank you for the answer I propose
now that oh sorry I was I heard from you
Richard but I'm proposing a comfort
break after that good good point to stop
for a for a relief okay okay yeah I'll
try and be brief on that basis uh so I I
propose to talk about the sort of
villages as as we're on that but the you
did mention uh earlier that uh the
working group uh had to unanimity uh in
terms of proposing this uh I sat on the
working group I I didn't I didn't buy
back this local plan so I just wanted
that to be be on record that said uh I
did go on all the site visits and uh
engage uh in the process and uh engage
with the parish councils as well and uh
and I I think it is reasonable to say
that the villages uh Parish councils
were listened to within within this
process uh so that in itself is is
appreciated I I would I would take on
board the point of counselor cooks that
the
um uh that uh is bursting at the seams I
think Newton others burst it seems
already so uh following up on on
councilman McGregor's point they are
sustainable locations they do have they
do have the railway stations and it does
seem rather odd that some cancers of of
have got Patches that uh that don't uh
don't aren't taking a great deal of
development uh when when they are
sustainable locations and and I'd still
reinforce that point that we should have
been looking for the higher density uh
locations nearer nearer those train
stations uh again uh councilor
um
uh Gary Taylor Made made a very good
point of whilst uh slightly slightly uh
that there was 150 uh uh units in in in
the plan uh 150 units and 750 per year
doesn't really touch the sides I thought
I think we're looking for sort of some
sort of revolution on that front so uh
so so
um it's disappointing uh the the the the
the coastal sustainable towns uh are not
taking that version thank you well I'm
just going to read out something very
briefly and then break for a comfort
back in the forward for word uh
introduction on this plan in finding
land for new development we've all been
Guided by three main principles taking
all opportunities to use Brown seals
sites first including redeveloping and
regenerating Town centers
two next ones with a DOT locating most
of the new homes close to job services
and sustainable transport and three
finding smaller sites for housing in
larger abilities to sustain essential
local facilities so that might be uh if
if you don't think that's quite right in
some of what we're doing the opportunity
we LED in the consultation with it to
point that out if you also wish now
let's come back if I may break close the
meeting for a comfort break and we'll
come back a couple of minutes after 12
o'clock my watch is 11 52 so I think
we'll have 10 minutes off now maybe if
is the canteen open over there or for a
coffee or
foreign
I'm not starting the meeting I just want
to say that taking up a few sandwiches
in the canteen so for those that haven't
got any lunch or or could do an extra
sandwiches they are doing that sort of
thing we will break for lunch later on
as close as one o'clock as we can get so
I just want to impart that information
thank you
a couple of minutes members please
foreign
right members we are going to break for
lunch so uh we can get back onto this
thank you
don't encourage them
all right I'll see what I can do
yeah okay
[Music]
right are we live streaming
we are we are well done
right if we can keep going so we've been
through one of the recommendations so
two to approve the policies map appendix
B for at least a six week period of pump
of public consultation everybody wanted
gone come into that one
three to approve sustainability
appraisal report appendix C for at least
six week period of public consultation
consenting a a view about the plan so
that um I'm sure they can but we'll have
we'll have an officer answer on that
without you know fettering their
discretion
um I reckon section 25 of the localism
ACT 2011 covers them but just to get
that agreed that town and Parish
councils can comment as corporate bodies
we'll have we'll have officer a comment
on that obviously Neil or Michelle the
answer is yes yes yeah oh thank you all
right
right we're rattling along
um
I did read out three so four was
approved the habitats regulations
appendix D for at least a six week
period of public consultations he's a uh
what's written down here approve uh five
approve the draft Community
infrastructure leveling uh charging
scheduled appendix C for at least a six
week period of public consultation
now hands up for these uh obviously uh
note the content of the consultation
statement for part one two and three
regulations uh 18 consultations appendix
s that that's six
nobody wants to comment on that uh seven
is not the content and conclusion of the
equity uh equality impact assessment
appendix G
and
I'll read out nine for the sake of it
the meeting Grant the delegated
authority to the head of place and
Commercial Services and consultation
with the executive member for plowing to
make minor changes to items one to six
prior to consultation to address any
editorial errors and matters of
clarification and nine
following the consultation submit the
proposed submission local plan 2020 to
2040 and Associated documents to the
Secretary of State
for the Department of leveling up
housing and communities to begin
proceedings for public examination
that was that was amended wasn't it
there it was an addition an addition
which which is what's going to be read
out there that's the additional wording
that Council that's forward on nine nine
well we're going to read out the
additional wording that councilor Taylor
put forward on nine this will include
granting delegated authority as a head
of place and Commercial Services in
consultation with the executive member
for planning and the chair of the local
working group to recommend minor
modifications to the inspector prior to
submission
while any major modifications will be
referred to full Council
so where do I move to now and this is it
10 now yeah and 10 is the new oh
councilman gray you won't comment on
that uh thank you Joe it was just to ask
that if any minor changes are made that
members are notified by email at least
just for openness and transparency
saying
thank you is that all right yeah I mean
what we did last time was produce a
schedule so you can see all of the
changes uh and we might have a track
change documents as well I just hope so
yeah any minor tweaks
and
micrones still aren't good and
recommendation 10 which is important I
think this is probably the most
important one of these the ones that
I've read out subject to the current
proposed changes to the National
planning policy framework coming into
effect which relates specifically to
housing requirements becoming advisory
the council commits to undertake a
review of the District council's of the
district not count you haven't got the
word council of the district's housing
needs immediately following adoption of
the 2040 local plan which takes into
account the forthcoming census-based
household and population
projection and if a lower housing
requirement is identified proceed with
an urgent partial review of the plan
which reflects a lower housing Target
that is what is recommendation can does
anybody want to comment on that
and councilor Andy Swain
thank you chair I imagine other people
want to comment on this I do think it's
fantastically important I want to say
I'm very grateful to the people that
have worked hard to get this
recommendation in place
the plan was prepared on the basis of
numbers in the National formula as we
all know and it was abruptly announced
in November without any warning that
that was now going to be optional but at
the same time it's clear from the
reports we've heard earlier that the law
hadn't changed to that point and
everything is very much up in the air
which leaves us in a bit of a mess but
importantly the the question the numbers
have always been mandatory which means
whether or not we agree with the numbers
has never been a question for us because
we don't have any choice now apparently
we may have a choice and I think it's
important that we have the opportunity
to make the most of that option
um
and that's why this amendment is really
important for me I would have struggled
to vote through the plan if there was a
risk of that fixing the numbers so that
they could then become optional that it
wouldn't be optional for us because we'd
already agree to them
um I hope that makes sense I do have a
question though now that the planning
formula is Up For Debate
um
I'm interested more than I was
previously in how it actually works
um if my understanding is correct the
numbers in teambridge are higher than in
many regions because in effect Cambridge
is an attractive place to live people
move in from other areas bringing money
with them and that pushes the house
prices up salaries in teambridge
compared to other areas are generally
low which means that housing is
relatively unaffordable in teambridge
and the standard formula applies an
uplift to the number of houses required
because houses are thought to be
unaffordable
um in general terms how big is that
uplift to what extent is teambridge has
to build more houses than a comparable
Authority would be if there wasn't the
perception of unaffordability thank you
very much
foreign
to that question uh and councilor Swain
makes a very good point about about the
calculation it's it's it's quite uh
fiendish looking but it's uh in essence
It's relatively simple uh it takes the
2011 census data which was which came
out in 2014 it gives us a data set to
look at which looks year on year out uh
into the into the uh near distance
um an expected household growth and that
that provides uh what I would call sort
of an underlying growth need but then
um it it takes a simple ish calculation
to uh which which relies on the
affordability of housing in the district
so it's that that's a variable that's
why we we were thinking we were going to
have to be putting 760 houses a year
into the local plan it's now 741 and
because the data sets have moved on the
affordability has gone up very slightly
I think it's 9.6 or there are
thereabouts
um and and perhaps house prices at that
point in time they might have just come
down a little bit but that still means
that we have to add
41 an additional 41 on top of the census
projections
thank you
it was an expert leader leader
uh thank you chairman
um I think it's very important I suspect
all cancers would agree with the view
that we need the right number rather
than just any number and clearly the
Secretary of State made an announcement
Before Christmas to say housing numbers
are not mandatory they're advisory
that's what was reported in the news in
all of the media that's what most people
have heard
but the reality is that the requirements
on councils in making a local plan
haven't actually changed we are required
to use the government standard formula
and that sets the number
I think we are all very Mindful and I'm
grateful for the help and support of
officers to provide the wording for
recommendation 10 which actually enables
the council to go forward assuming we
agree to go into consolidation today to
go forward with a robust plan that meets
the government's current requirements
so we can go forward with confidence on
that but also gives the assurance that
if When government hold firm to their
word and change their regulations that
we can then come back as a council and
reassess that housing number if
government do what they say they do
for me in all of this and not to revisit
too much my last local plan which I'm of
the current local plan which I voted
against we had a big argument in Council
about what the housing number were and
at that time as I recall there were
several housing formula and we spent
some long time in Council considering
that I'll view my view at the time was
500 a year would have been the right
number but actually as Neil Blaney has
said earlier today when it went to
assessment and the independent inspector
reviewed it a decision was made and
that's where we are and consequently
we are where we are now because of
government regulation and I think all of
us will
understand the Injustice that councils
like teambridge are how to how to
account for house building when in fact
we don't build houses okay we we have
built you know new affordable Council
houses but we are not a house Builder
and if a house bill is starting to go
slow because we are entering in to a
recession and they build less
what powers do we as a council have
actually these National position is
about government requiring developers to
build out and deliver
but I think we'd all recognize as well
one of the big issues in teambridge is
affordability of housing
and there was an argument that the more
you build the cheaper they become but
actually that's not true
it's not about the more you build it's
actually about recognizing the problem
for nowadays for people is often
invested on developers agreeing High
land prices for the land they're
building on
but also because I think actually and
many of us might well agree but my view
has always been actually what we need to
get back to is council's Building
Council houses modern affordable Cancers
and actually that would address so many
issues that we face with over 1200
people on our housing waiting list
chairman I'm going to vote in favor of
the recommendations both of those Seto
and as amended recommendation nine and
ten because I think it allows us to move
forward to regulation 19 but it also
gives us that precious option of
reviewing this again when and if the
government change regulations and I
would ask all cancers support the
recommendations I've set out in order to
defend both districts from predatory and
unwarranted development in order to meet
the government's requirements and to
ensure that we have that backstop which
regulation recommendation 10 provides
thank you chairman
councilor McGregor
thank you again chair
um thank you for your comments councilor
con it
um one of the points I made earlier was
about whether the district would
consider
um looking again uh it was discussed in
2019 at the possibility of uh being a an
LDC local Development Corporation itself
which would enable it to develop
land and build houses to meet local
residents needs both in terms of
affordability and social housing it's
something that perhaps we may need to
consider for the future maybe not right
at this moment in time but hopefully
fellow members would would agree that
that would be a good plan certainly as
far as local residents needs are
concerned thank you
councilor Wrigley
uh thank you I can assure councilor
McGregor that we are doing everything we
can to build as many Council homes as we
can at the moment there is no need for
us to take that step but should that be
necessary in the future I'm sure it's
something we may well consider
right we've had the recommendation
proposed Now's the Time to vote on this
please if if I may and you've seen the
recommendations here we've read them all
out one to ten included uh so may I ask
for a show of hands please uh of all
those in favor of it
again against
how many four and abstentions
four against right so that is passed
thank you thank you very much indeed for
the speed at which we got through it I
was dreading being here at five o'clock
and it looks as though we're going to be
let off the hook as it were uh right we
moved to the next item on the agenda if
we can please
item 11 it is now which is the
recommendation from the executive of the
third of January notice of motion uh
lasting Memorial to the late Queen
Elizabeth II acknowledge
uh and acknowledges the Ascension of
King Charles III all right uh who's
presenting this councilor Connor
thank you chairman this is a motion put
forward by councilor Boulevard uh to
last Council kanjo executive and this is
the executor's recommendation to council
which is to support the intent of
planting two trees
um funded by underspends from the
council's Community Fund and if that
isn't sufficient then from savings
elsewhere in this financial year
chairman and councilman I know that we
should speak to his motion but that's
for me just to Simply introduce the
executive recommendation thank you
chairman
uh yeah councilor Cox wants to speak
France uh bulletin please
yes
I'm grateful to the leader for um and
the executive for recommending that the
proposal moves ahead obviously it's very
rare that uh we have the opportunity to
celebrate a monarch who's been on the
throne for 70 years and I think it's
appropriate for the future generations
of people of timber at timbridge that
they have something to which they can
look back on and recognize the
contribution that her majesty made to
this country and community at the same
time recognizing the accession of King
Charles III is something that we gain we
should recognize so putting two trees
together of a suitable desire or
suitable type within the grounds of Ford
house is something that we should all be
proud of and I certainly welcome the
support of the executive and thank them
for their recommendation that this
should proceed and I ask all fellow
councilors to join with me and thank
them and approve this investment on
behalf of the people of timbridge thank
you
councilor Cox I'd like to amend that
that I totally agree with that
everything except for the payment it
should be done by crowdfunding and only
Council funds should be used if the
crowdfunding proposal doesn't produce
enough money why not let everybody in
teamage all the people Scout Troops
people clubs societies
individuals make a contribution to this
so they can say they've done that and we
could perhaps provide them with a
certificate to say they've contribute to
this let the people of Tunbridge pay for
this to show their love for our late
Queen and stepped on it before counselor
McGregor
thank you gentlemen I don't support the
amendment that councilor Cox has put
forward
councilor McGregor
thank you chair
um much has been made in this meeting so
far of the cost of living crisis the
difficulties that the country faces
going forward
I would rather every single spare Penny
of my counselor Community Fund was given
to food banks or to perhaps add value to
the council tax reduction scheme
um we already have as a council a tree
planting schedule
it wouldn't be too difficult to within
the current budget divert
that to include two trees for Ford Park
there is a whole range of trees from
whips to saplings it's all local natural
choices for the trees that are being
planted so there would be no difficulty
in sourcing that
um and I I don't
want to see the Community Fund going to
um this project where when in fact we're
already planting trees but thank you
very much
leader
thank you chairman it's just worth
reminding ourselves that during covid we
use Cancer's Community Fund to support
the food banks as a council we support
very well citizen advice CVS nacta for
example Newton Abbott community
Transport in the council tax we are
probably one of the 33 councils
nationally that provide 100 council tax
relief in the budget coming forward for
next year while we are proposing a five
pound fifty for a year increase we're
also proposing a five pound fifty four
refund across the board so this council
is doing a lot to support
families and people in teambridge
through the cost of living crisis
I understand entirely what council
McGregor says that there is you know
good tree planting program going on I
think cancer Boulevard's motion was more
about the specific issue of
commemorating 70 years of service by Her
Majesty of the queen to mark that but
also this section of King Charles III to
the throne
the easiest way to actually fund that so
we shouldn't have unfunded propositions
was in the unspent Cancer's Community
Fund which at the end of each year there
is generally money left unspent
well I'd say to councilors is if you are
concerned about your money possibly
being used to support these two trees
and get it spent in your area before the
end of the program which is I think the
season cuts off at the end of February
because of the election paid a period so
get it spent
if you're not minded if you don't worry
about it if you're happy to support it
then leave money in your cancers
Community Fund but for some people they
won't spend it all and that's the first
call and if that isn't sufficient then
we will find the money from other
General savings within the council's
end-of-year resources for what
effectively will be a quite modest
amount of chairman I hope that reassures
counselors that what we're trying to do
here is acknowledge that there is
widespread respect and regard for her
late Majesty
and it's just true trees were planting
not a spare
also an independent next and then
councilor McGregor
but I actually agree with actually
McGregor about and trying to use the
funds that's already there am I concern
about the Community Fund
um
is for example I've got money in my life
and some of it is not going to go out
till March so I'd hate to get to it
oh
get to it closer to march to find it
wasn't in there if there is a limit and
I've got to sort it before February I
will but
I just think that in unless it's the
money that's just not going to be spent
then that that's a different matter but
some of us have got it committed but
can't take it out later Council of
chronic will clarify this well I'm
clarified
the council's Committee Fund will close
early this year in order to avoid the
perder period so I think I think a
date's been given the members newsletter
we will try and get that reissue but I
think it's around about the end of
February so I'd say to councilor Patrick
get your money out before the end of
February when the scheme closes what's
left that can't hasn't been allocated by
cancers well the first call will be
towards these The Proposal that kinds of
boulevards made for two trees so I say
to councilors
get the money spent if you want it in
your area get it spent what's left when
the scheme closes at the end of February
or whatever date that is we'll then go
towards these trees so you won't
suddenly find that your money's gone it
will only be taken when the scheme
closes I think that's made it clear
councilman Gregory wanted to speak again
thank you chair
um at the last meeting this was
discussed
um councilor Swain
um quite rightly asked the question
whether this was going to be compulsory
to which the answer was a resounding no
this looks like compulsory by the back
door to me and as such I would like that
to be noted that I do not wish any
bounds of the Community Fund to go to
this particular project I think it can
be dealt with within the current uh uh
tree planting schedule I don't think it
needs anything extra I don't think we
should be spending taxpayers funds on
this when there are much more needy
cases within our own District requiring
support thank you chair
hang on councilor Malone
hi um I I have in the past been called
an anarchist by councilor Boulevard I do
in fact have nothing but fondness for
the lake queen and I I have no problem
with this as an idea but I I can't see
how in the current climate we can take
money from that would otherwise be going
to Club societies people who desperately
need it right now for something that
really I mean for God's sake how much
does two trees cost when I think about
all the money that has been wasted by
this Council in the last four years on
boom and bus projects and dodgy
consultations and now you're going to
tell people that you can't afford two
trees if we want to put these trees in
the ground then let's just vote for the
council to put the trees in the ground
right Chancellor chronic wants to come
back on this
John just to clarify
as I said if you want to use your
councilor's Community Fund use it spend
it get it out in your area right now
when the scheme closes when the scheme
closes as in you will not be able to
allocate because the scheme is closed
due to the election period of period
Then any unspent monies any unallocated
monies will be used towards funding
these trees so I say to council known
it's Beverly valid question spend the
money spend the money but what's left
unspent will be used so no one's robbing
anyone of anything no one's taking money
that would have gone to a community
group because it stands on the
councilors to get the money into their
Community groups and if they don't do
that the underspend will be used
well there's no Amendment that's
actually been put forward by it but it's
actually been seconded so with that in
mind let's go to the vote on the
original motion
all those in favor
those against
those abstaining
so the motion is carried thank you
right where are we now
see no no
it's the notice of motion it's the
motion notice the motion 12
all right this is uh the timoth hospital
notice the motion that's been put
forward
was the so we do we go to council Cox to
speak on the motion we do
yes I understand that
thank you
um no one can have missed what's
happening to our NHS and uh the tomb of
Hospital motion is about a Pacific
Hospital but it's about a system and
it's about saving Tim a possible not for
Nostalgia not to have Hattie Jakes as
the matron and to go back to carry on
doctor and as I've been accused of being
a Luddite I'm not it's for good sound
medical reasons that we want Tim of
hospital to be retained as a
Rehabilitation Unit uh unit unit it's a
different to the use to what it was
originally built for but it's a
continuous place to help people with
medicine and we though we talk about
Nostalgia and people sentiment to people
they are feelings of the heart and if we
keep Tim of Hospital open we will have
the league of friends we will have
people who will volunteer and help the
hospital because they'll see it as
theirs and of course it is this because
the lab the land was originally built
before the NHS was bought by the people
of tinmouth Sheldon and Bishop Stanton
and so I hope Council councils will
support all the executive and Council
subsequently will support this motion so
I so move
uh
thank you
thank you for putting that motion
forward my if I can say personally from
the chair I'd love to see this motion
debated today and put to to bed is there
support in the council I would like to
propose from the chair that it's debated
today if I may and that's seconded for
that so can we have a vote
oh yeah all right
we have very many members of the public
from timoth come this morning and and
wisely and based on previous experience
we advise them that this may be a very
long meeting I don't think anyone
perhaps expected that they might
wouldn't be at this stage of the agenda
right now
if we debate it right here and right now
those people have left and they won't
hear that debate and so I would
respectfully suggest actually that we
take it to Executive where those people
make wish to come and they can
contribute but actually it will then
come back to the next Council where it
will be on the agenda for a debate and I
think actually the debate May well be
widened out by members from timoth to
talk about Community Hospitals and the
valid part and we're here in the NHS
about the booking hotels to move people
out from acute hospitals so I think
there is a debate to be had but I will
respectfully suggest it may appear a
discourteseet of the residence of
tinmouth who came today and were advised
that this may be a very little meeting
of her left if we then proceeded to
debate it all
I hear what you're saying it's councilor
McGregor would like to speak
thank you chair as the person who
seconded the
um second to do on the on the matter of
the debate uh perhaps uh might need to
get some screen wipes for uh councilor
conduct's glasses because if he looks to
his left and front he'll see a very
large screen which reflects what's being
broadcast on YouTube currently and live
streaming there's a very large amount of
camera locations around the room I see
myself on the screen there and I'm sure
that if energy is in tinmouth who wants
to follow the debate all they need to do
is follow the live streaming and I think
it's a priority now that we discuss it
now delaying it by weeks and months
simply pushes back the problem and the
reason I say that is that it's needed
now is because the National Health
Service and the government are already
talking about purchasing care beds
timoth hospital is an existing location
it's ideal for anybody who wants to work
in the care sector
who lives in tinmouth because there is
limited travel costs for them and it's
not a well-paid sector to work in and I
think it's a really good opportunity for
us to discuss it and debate it now
I can take the decision that the council
um or the the motion to the board
meeting on the 8th of February at Torbay
NHS trust so that we can actually start
talking about it there so pushing it
back is simply delaying that opportunity
thank you chair councilor Dawes wants to
speak please
I thought that when uh the members of
the public came uh and this motion
wasn't brought forward that they were
advised that they could go home and
watch the debate on uh on YouTube so I I
would have thought that we'd be doing
them a great disservice they're taking
time out of their day their working days
probably people taking days off to come
and uh and and listen to something that
they felt very strongly and passionately
against I would imagine they'd be quite
disgruntled if we just keep the can down
the road and put it into another another
debate and ask them to say other days
are their time to follow something the
ghost or executive then goes to another
full Council uh I can't understand why
why we wouldn't debate it today
well I've tabled the amendment which has
been seconded which is before any debate
or not takes place we have to vote on
whether there's two-thirds of the
council would like to debate it so would
you raise your hands please if you want
to see uh them debated today please
do an accurate
two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen
fourteen so
um
15 with you
so it's it has the motion to debate it
today failed or not yes yes and the
motion has failed so it won't be debated
today it will go to the executive uh to
the is it to the next executive meeting
indeed Mexico so do we know when that is
for the benefit of those watching on
YouTube it's the seventh uh February and
it'll be held here the 7th of February
for those watching uh here out of
Buckland yes here at Buckland uh thank
you very much that that passes that
particular uh one for now
so where are we going now noticeable
motion over the page
was the last item is it counselor
question the library we're gonna have
lunch here and laughter
all right counseling questions yes
would you like to read out the the or
Draw us attention to the question
members were circulated with the
councilor questions and responses
um so it's um councilor Gordon hope for
his question and the response was
circulated
thank you
I'm very pleased to note the
clarification from the leader and I
thank him for his answer I'm glad that
there are no plans nor have there ever
been any plans uh as suggested
does the leader feel that those who
mislead
the public and in so doing denigrate the
council should apologize
does he anticipate such an apology
foreign
you know
thank you chairman I um saw an article
in one of the online news media talking
about the virtual demolition today
um
I think there has been a lot of
misinformation I'm grateful to councilor
Gordon hook for his question I don't
anticipate an apology but yes I do think
they should thank you okay okay
clarification on what you're talking
about I'm sorry well
there was a question table uh from from
councilor hook you should have a copy of
that there councilman he said okay well
I let me let me just help because it's
not going to take a second to do can the
leader clarify if there are are or
indeed ever have been any plans to
demolish the Alexandra Theater Alexander
Cinema and response from the leader
there have never been any plans to
demolish the Alexandria Cinema you heard
a supplementary question and you heard
the answer to that does that help you
out
uh in part yes
okay so so there's no there's no
debatable questions I'm afraid can I
just ask that when um members of the
ruling executive want to make these
statements they actually name who they
are talking about so that it's nice and
clear for everyone and not as they do in
the news media use sniveling weasily
type Expressions no no no so that we all
know who we're talking about but they
don't quite have the backbone to say it
thank you question Mr Jones yeah I I
mean I have it there councilman I have
there outlined the whole thing for you
so yeah I hear what you say I'm afraid
I'm going on to the next question
the next
the next question from the everything's
been answered and it's I've read it out
I read the answers out and show you hold
you held all the replies I'm reading out
the net for the benefit of you of the
next question I'm reading the next
question out as your iPad isn't working
the next question is from councilor
David Cox question to the leader will
the leader provide an update on disposal
of council owned land in teignmouth to
the NHS for the planned new health and
well-being Center the response from the
leader as it reads out the council
remains in negotiations with the NHS
regarding the disposal of land at
Brunswick Street I hope that matters can
be concluded by the end of this
financial year with the receipt
available in 23 24 to support the
council's capital program of investment
across the district I've asked officers
to confirm with the NHS that they're
able to proceed and report back to the
council at the earliest opportunity if
the plan transfer over of the land for
the health and well-being Center has
stalled for any reason all right the
Council of Cox do you have a
supplementary question to that
are we going to put a deadline on the
NHS I mean they've been dragging their
feet over this I think they want us to
give in to them for nothing but they're
not going to get it for nothing so um
are we going to put a debt on or will we
look to put a deadline I expect the
leader will be asked to be able to
answer your supplementary question
Council would be aware
that the matter was debated and decided
by cancer and I've asked councils to
follow up with the NHS and as soon as
there's anything further to report them
it will be reported okay
excuse me a minute
I mean questions counselor Russell and
there's not
you shouldn't be making a statement
no I'm not here I'm awfully sorry I'm
not here there's no provision and
doesn't need anything for that by all
means send an email out to all the
counselors if you feel they want to know
something
right question from councilor doors
uh question to the leader given the
police station is now open at Newton
Abbott is the leader assured that the
residents of teambridge can be more
confident that the rule of law will be
applied in the district the verbal
response will be given from the leader
thank you chairman I'm grateful to
cancel the doors for the question I'd
like to First congratulate all those in
the community
members of this Council and particularly
Newtown the Town Council who campaigned
for the reopening of Newton Abba police
station I'm sure that within the
community within another there is much
relief and happiness that there is a
police presence back at the police
station chairman thank you
uh thank you very much Alan for that
response uh we've gone through the
business supplementary oh supplementary
sorry
supplementary yet
hi yes I I've got a supplementary uh the
uh the the last uh full council meeting
I asked for clarification from the
monitoring officer on why I was
disallowed to speak on the matter of the
Alexandra theater the uh the theater the
in the courts of British plans was going
to be demolished uh in in terms of the
Interior that clarification was supposed
to be sent in writing to me uh and and
hasn't been uh my understanding is that
that advice was in the breach of uh in
breach of the law Local Government Act
uh and also the council brought forward
a standards complaint against me in 2020
which uh my understanding is uh breach
the law as well so I'd like to know if
the if the monitoring officer would uh
provide that clarification or apologize
so I'd like the clarification in writing
or an apology uh and would the council
uh seek to apologize for uh bringing
unlawful standards a complaint against
me in 2020.
councilor chairman
um it was a question to me and the
supplementary ought to be relevant to me
yes and the supplementary is not
relevant thank you chairman okay okay uh
that concludes the the councilor's
question
um and we're moving towards the end of
the meeting I'd just like to I've
forgotten counselors to announcements to
send my good wishes to uh Charles
Nuttall who couldn't uh it wasn't well
enough to attend it let's hope he gets
better and makes a full recovery to good
health and I'm sure that's the wishes of
this this Council be done but on a
humorous note if I have to get Miss paid
out to print to plant the new two trees
I'll be very happy to see you all there
that concl that concludes the meeting
thank you very much everybody for
attending
foreign